hier ist eine frage ganz klar am anfang
die spd geschrumpft dort in nordrhein
westfalen ist das auch kanzler schuld
auch ganz sicher aber nicht nur der
kanzler also die das bild das die spd
ihren der ampel koalition in berlin
abgibt ist verheerend im moment da wäre
nach dieser wahl dringend eine
kabinettsumbildung auf der spd-seite
notwendiges müssen raus die
verteidigungsministerin unter
gesundheitsminister doch da darf er gar
nicht warten bis der im nächsten herbst
wieder eine spur der verwüstung hinter
sich her zieht das muss er gerade ziehen
man hat gemerkt dass offensichtlich die
wähler auch in nrw die grünen quasi als
eine autonome kraft in der ampel
koalition wahrnehmen die haben ihren
kleinen kanzler dass es herr habeck und
die haben ihre außenministerin die beide
hervorragend ankommen und ansonsten gibt
es dann eben eine sehr gute verbogene
merkwürdige unfassbare spd und eine fdp
von der man sowohl im bund als auch in
nrw sagen muss die hat
unglücklicherweise die falschen ämter
übernommen den beiden regierungen und
zwar zwei ämter hat die ihnen gar nichts
bringen da finanzminister ständig
schulden macht bringt der partei nichts
sie müssen nicht weg ersparen deswegen
ganz kurz an sie noch einmal die frage
wie hansjörg wyss aufgeworfen hat raus
mit den ministern also raus mit
lamprecht lauers mit lauterbach würden
sie das tun
das muss der bundeskanzler entscheiden
ich will mich da wissen sie ich finde
das immer schwierig kommen gerade von
sechs sieben acht monaten aus einer
regierung die abgewählt worden ist
jedenfalls der unions teil deswegen
würde ich da jetzt nicht in diese
persönlichen bewertungen hineingehen
aber herr jörges hat doch einiges dazu
gesagt ich frage auch der schlägen weil
das natürlich schon ding es angehörige
familienmitglieder mit fliegen zu lassen
in der luftwaffe der bundeswehr im
luftwaffen heli was ist ihre meinung
dazu wir sind ich habe es ja selbst auch
erlebt in der pandemie und übrigens auch
zurecht erlebt und durchlebt das
natürlich ist auch meine frage ist in
welchen zeiten sind wir gerade was ist
die situation auf der bürgerinnen und
bürger die pandemie war eine harte zeit
und da musste ich mich auch manche
debatte stellen und damit natürlich ganz
genau geschaut wie verhalten sich auch
regierungsmitglieder und das gilt
natürlich in dieser kriegszeit in europa
noch viel viel mehr und in der frage der
bundeswehr der bundeswehr ausstattung
und da verstehe ich schon dass viele
bürgerinnen und bürger sich sehr stören
an diesen bildern aber vor allem auch
wie ich finde an dem umgang anschließend
damit das ist der eine minister fall der
andere den han sol jörges aufgeworfen
hat ist lauterbach lauterbach sagt heute
direkt vor der wahl waren zitat aus der
rheinischen post die cdu ist wegen der
impfpflicht die sie mit verhindert hat
die sie auch die auch sie nie wirklich
wollten schuld wenn es künftig mehr
corona tod einmal aufgetreten mit genau
ich lasse weise dazu fehlen mir jetzt
viel ein zu sagen aber ich habe mir eins
vorgenommen und das wissen sie ich werde
die korona politik die aktuelle nicht
kommentieren ich finde das macht jetzt
gar nicht um seine ich frage das wäre
ich um seine politik da geht es um einen
krassen vor der naja es widerspricht er
den eigentlich was selbst mal gesagt
worden ist in der bundestagsdebatte dass
man eben nicht in vorwürfe verfallen
will anscheinend ist die not jetzt so
groß aber ich sage noch einmal ich werde
ansonsten aktuell doch nicht mal bei dtv
aktuelle corona und irak danach weil ich
das weiß und das ist keine bewertung des
ministers sondern das ist eine antwort
auf ein krasses zitates von ihnen kommt
von karl lauterbach und das krass trifft
schon ziemlich cool